what's going on guys welcome to another
sequel in Python tutorial video where we
left off who actually made the database
now let's go ahead and make a table give
the parameters of that table and then
even maybe insert some data into that
table so first thing that we want to go
ahead and do is let's let's let's do
show databases you should get a good
idea where we are again so as you can
see we've got that default and then
we've got tutorial we want to go into
tutorials so we're gonna say use and
then whatever your username is mine's
beginner accountant dollar sign and then
a table name mine was tutorial so now
it's gonna say database change so now
you're in that database now you could
use describe and see what it is but it's
gonna be empty for now so now what we
want to do is create a table in that
database so to create a table
you're gonna go create table then give
the table name wisely me tell look and
cookies for whoever figures it out now
the next thing is you want to give the
names of the columns and then the data
types of those columns so we're gonna
say the first column is going to be a
time so we're going to go through a unix
time in here now a lot of people what
they're gonna do is make the first
column an auto incrementing or self
incrementing key and that's gonna be
their primary key for me look I mean I
use time series data for everything so I
just use the time in UNIX form as the
first column and that's my own little
auto incrementing key if you want to be
official and you know use everyone's
protip you can make an auto incrementing
key if you want i'm just notifying you
that that's i'm making the conscious
decision not to so time time is going to
be an int and then we're going to allow
it to be 13 long just simply because
they like normally it's like I think 11
something characters but we're gonna
throw out like some random numbers in
there so the next thing that we're going
to do is once we've defined time we're
going to go ahead and say the next
column is a username column in the
username column we're going to make
a bar car and that's just gonna be a
variable character so if you just made
it like car it would require that the
data in that column would always be 20
long whereas if you make it far card
doesn't have to be 20 long it can be 5
long and it won't like force it to still
be 20 so we'll use bar car there and
then the next column we're gonna make it
a tweet and then we're gonna do the same
thing var car and with a max of course
140 so that's how you create the table
so let's go ahead and throw it a little
semicolon here all you poor Python
programmers man you have a hard time
with sequel anyway
query okay zeros affected of course new
rows were actually affected so now we're
done so now just as an aside other data
types you can have a date text blob set
enum and also float and they're pretty
much all the same as far as their data
type floats the only funky one where the
first digit or the first number
represents like how many digits there
are and the second one represents how
many decimal points but anyway maybe
we'll talk about that later but for now
I'll keep it basic so now we can do once
we've done that is well we've got the
table made so the first thing you can do
is a command called show tables so we
can see table is indeed there and then
we can also describe table and figure
out like what this table is all about so
there's this little description of the
table all the fields the type null if
their primary key or not default extra
if they have auto incrementing etc so
that's that now our goal is eventually
to do all of these SQL queries within
Python all that but there's gonna be
some times where one you want to know
how to do it by hand also every query
that you write within Python is going to
be an SQL query so it's gonna be the
same stuff we're right now or right now
the only difference is if you want to
say you want to write a variable there
will be a little subtle change but
nothing nothing too difficult to make
the shift for Plus whenever you do
especially like deletes sometimes I
prefer to do a delete by hand especially
if it's like a tricky one so it's you
just want to know this stuff so anyway
not wasting your time insert into and
that's gonna put data and do the table
and now you need to say what table so
when I say tell look from my table
whatever you called yours you can call
it whatever values and then in here
we're going to insert the values in the
order of column now again later this
will change whenever we insert instead
of you know hard-coded values variables
but for now we'll just write it out so
we're going to put data in here like
this now in here this is an int so there
are gonna be no quotations around what
we say so we're gonna say 1 3 8 5 4 1 9
9 6 9 as a UNIX timestamp that's that
next is our user name and our user name
here is just going to be set Dex and
then we're gonna say a tweet and this
will be welcome to my tutorial and as
always don't forget your semicolons cuz
you will query okay one row affected
whole set so now what we can do is let's
insert a couple more things so I'm just
gonna to make it easy
hit this will change it will say this
occurs one second later so the end will
be 70 will still use the name sent Dex
and the tweet will change up the tweet
this tweet will be these are all real
tweets by the way wow thanks at Obama
you are right these tutorials rock his
words not mine
so that's another one and then finally I
just do one more tweet just to give us
some data to work with so one more
second later I got this tweet from
another guy you guys might know one and
this one is at Bill Gates thanks Bill I
know him on a first name basis I respect
him then it's all capitalized his name
thanks Bill for the job offer as VP
but I wanna keep ops open so that's my
sweet back to him he offered me a vice
president job anyway
done query done now we're done so now if
we want to see our data we can run a
select command here and we'll just say
select asterisk first like all from and
then we want to select that from todo
and now we can see that the contents of
our database so the first one was
welcome next one was me chit-chatting
with Obama and just saying he's writing
his thoughts and the next the final line
was me turned down Bill Gates job offer
so those are just the basics of creating
the database or creating the table
rather and then inserting some data into
that table now in the next video I'm
gonna be talking about how to make some
updates to this table and not any more
inserting but updating the leading and
retrieving data
so anyway stay tuned for that video as
always thanks for watching thanks for
the support in subscriptions and until
next time